yeah so today we we have a rather mixed
bag we're starting off with two ATP
talks on on the LHC then we move towards
severe weather and finish off with
robotics
I want to thank Katerina and been a lot
for the first two talks today there was
you know this unexpected travel but
another illness and they have filled in
perfectly with these talks and I think
they'll go nicely with each other one
setting us up for the other and so I
will give it to Katerina thank you thank
you very much for the invitation and for
their attention I will I understand that
you really like acronyms because ha HCP
at LHC and I'm sure that will like
three-letter acronyms TAS a lot as well
so the talk today is heavily based on
material from a number of people here
and it's also partly based on a workshop
that precedes this by a few years that
matters the data science at LHC workshop
and this is a series that the Simons
Foundation has also have been interested
in and I'm going to talk about what it
means to make real-time decisions at the
LHC it's a fairly personal view and it's
a mostly considered a series of
discussion points rather than me talking
so please interact I'm giving you a
fairly high-level view of things as I'm
not necessarily an expert in all the
things that I'm talking about but we
have some experts in the room and if you
have questions that I don't know how to
answer I just shut them off so let's
start with the outline so I'm going to
talk about five points first I'll
introduce you the Large Hadron Collider
an atlas this doesn't need too much of
an introduction most people know what
what this is and then I will go more in
detail on the LHC experiment trigger
systems so what is a trigger it's not
great to talk about triggers in this
political climate right now but maybe we
will rename it eventually but this is
what decides in our detector whether to
keep
data or not so this is the the key point
for for this talk here and then the last
part is going to be on how and why to
make the most of LHC data I work on that
matters so the examples that I'm going
to use are related to dark matter and I
hope this makes the astrophysicist in
their own feel a bit at home and then
finally I conclude with something that
links more when it talks yesterday on
how to do the monitoring and what it
means to monitor detectors and data
taking so let's start with the not quite
real-time this is a graph that has made
the rounds is from the economist and
this is the various particles of the
standard model of particle physics in
years on the x axis from the concept
from the theoretical concept to the
discovery so there's only two real-time
discoveries here if you consider the
fact that they were discovered before
they were theorized but most of the
other particles took a while and
especially the the Higgs boson took the
longest somehow it was theorized in the
60s and then in 2012 we found evidence
for it so the the first point to take
home here is that particle physics
discoveries requires very large
instrument and sometimes a lot of time
so it's not an instant discovery so what
does it take to discover a Higgs boson
and let's see for them yes
so you need a particle collider and
something that makes a lot of particles
collide not a lot at the same time not
necessarily but in a very high frequency
particle collider because this kind of
processes what you see on the y-axis is
the number of events and on the x axis
is the die photon invariant mass that is
connected to the mass of the higgs boson
that you see here this is the Higgs
boson bump this is very rare it's if you
have six hundred thousand collisions per
second but only one in ten to thirteen
or so contains a Higgs boson so you need
a high rate Collider to begin with you
need also a detector that is able to
select and precisely measure photos and
here I'm talking about atoms in CMS
mostly but there's also other detectors
at the LHC and each of those has
millions of readout channel so you can
think about rate times number of
channels this is a very large volume of
data
and then you need the people you need
teams that operate the detector you need
to calibrate the photons or all the
other objects that fake photos for
example and then do the data analysis so
come up with this nice data - faith
where the Higgs boson actually appears
so you mean this is the bins right
they're correlated noise so yeah you you
have to deal with the correlations to
beam by beam correlation and come can
come from many different sources like
the energy scale if you don't measure
the energy of a given photon precisely
then it might migrate into a different
plane and this is one kind of
correlation there's many others you can
also decide to make better than real
time discoveries here and here I don't
know if there's any theorist in the room
they might get offended but there's a
maybe you've heard in December 2015 that
there was a in the same distribution as
the as where the Higgs boson were
discovered there was a small excess and
you can possibly see why I possibly
maybe if you really squid and here is
the it's a website that the it's not
just for high energy physics it's for
more for for many other fields where
where you have the announcement of such
plots because they only become public
after a really intense peer review and
internal vetting so you have you make an
announcement and then this would this
happen on the 15th of December up 14 and
then at 16 47 someone had seven pages
about it so that that's great this is
real-time data analysis or someone
picked up a paper from a printer what
are the two so this was just a
facilities point but so what is
real-time analysis at LHC experiment
this is a definition that might or might
not work it's not a quantitative
definition but there's this is what you
do with a first pass data analysis that
you have to do it in short timescales
with the limited amount of information
and it can influence further data taking
so this is the definition I'll use for
real-time analysis and the first part of
this talk will consider
the data analysis done within the
trigger system where you have to decide
whether to record a data event or not
and the timescales and are involved are
of the order microseconds for the lowest
level of the decision so I start with
looking at the Large Hadron Collider in
its experiment and you know that it's 27
kilometers of circumference Collider
that collides protons against protons
and then collect collisions are recorded
and analyzed by four main experiments
and this is I'm going to talk mostly
about CMS LHC be and Atlas so the first
thing I'll try is to show a video what
might or might not work yes so you've
seen some of you that have seen Ilyas
talk yesterday have already seen this
but the thing is pretty spectacular to
see how deep underground these
experiments are so this is a hundred and
seventy five meter underground
experiments it's a tunnel where the
protons circulate and there's four
really large experiments we'll see the
size of them later where the particles
that are accelerated up to very very
close to the speed of light end up
colliding and then it's the experiments
that see the products of these
collisions and this is one example of
one collision you see the the tracks and
the energy deposits in the colorimeters
the done then get 600 million times per
second get then distributed to computing
so we'll see the computing part later
now let's stop a little on the CMS
detector you see how big it is compared
to people here and this is called
compact so it's it's not quite but it's
a it's more compact than Atlas but this
is the tens of meters detectors and
another impressive thing is that you see
that there's many different technologies
and many different parts of this
detector many sub detectors that are
used to measure the particle properties
and the information is reconstructed for
each collision event and what you call
an event is the combination of all the
information from all this this detector
in a that gets turned into particles
can i push in request so what extent is
coincidence necessary coincidence at a
very high time resolution necessary to
its user yeah so it's used within the
detector in well there's two ways you
can use it you can you need to have some
coincidence of your electronics with the
punch the collisions of the LHC and you
can use timing in that way although of
course the response of the calorimeters
and response of the tracking is not
necessarily instant so you have some
buffering that that happens within the
sub detectors but at least you have a
timestamp for each of the collisions and
then there's a thing that I'm not going
to talk about but it's quite a nice
development of LHC detectors is timing
detectors so you can actually use time
information very very precise time
information so you can measure the time
of the one the particle arrives in your
detector and then use that information
for doing analysis relative to the time
separation between the events that's a
question on requires a ton of paper so
you get pileup from the events that have
gone through previously effectively
signal of events are being recorded now
so coincidence is kind of a it's
coincidence
it's not like you have ways to store the
event and understand what out of time
pileup is what he's talking about
there's it's not the simultaneous
collisions it's the one from before and
after yeah
so another remarkable thing of these
detectors is that you can't quite see
the scale here but this is the number
that the fraction of channel that work
and in a detector like this there's
millions of millions of channels and all
the sub detectors have more than 95% of
channels that actually work and it's
we're quite far into the the first the
first run we started running in 2010 so
it's I think it's it's marvelous that
things work maybe I'm not thinking this
way but and it's all thanks to the
people of the experimental collaboration
so I've taken some pictures of the just
a small part of Atlas CMS LHCb
and Alice but you can imagine that this
is these are really large experimental
collaborations up to three thousand
three thousand five hundred people per
experiment and also you probably
understand that the our author list
sometimes is longer than the paper
itself and that creates some interesting
sociological questions that though we
can discuss in a coffee break all right
let's go on to the data delivery so here
we are talking about a quantity that is
called the integrated luminosity and
that is the amount of data that is
collected
there's also another quantity that is
the center of mass energy this is the
number seven to thirteen and that is how
many that you can discover more massive
particles no more energy essentially so
these are the two figures of Merit of a
Collider
how much data it gives you and at what
energy it gives you the data and you see
here that in the progression from 2010
you can't quite see on this on the scale
the the data the amount of data given
compared to 2017 so there's orders of
magnitude more one or two orders of
magnitude more data delivered in the
same time in 2017 with respect to 2010
so we are now in a production mode for
the LHC it's running very well it's
giving us the data that we need
so what does the machine parameter mean
for experiments we have up to at the
moment 30 megahertz bunch crossing
frequency so there's one collision after
25 nanoseconds and the consequences that
detectors needs both fast electronics
but also good buffer you can't quite
keep the whole event and process it in
25 nanoseconds and the other the other
thing is that if you want a lot of
collisions think about being in two
opposite sides of the room and trying to
throw a tiny tiny ping pong balls at
each other you'll never hit these are
protons so this is a thought experiment
that makes me think you need a lot of
protons if you want some of them to
collide because they're small so there's
a about 3,000 punches per beam each of
them has 10 to the 11 protons and there
are 600 million collisions per second as
a consequence in the hope of producing
something interesting such as the Higgs
boson so the consequence is that yes
there will be one collision that you
want among many that you might not want
so this is called pileup and that the
current that taking we have up to 70
simultaneous collisions but for the high
luminosity LHC run we plan to go up to
200 and usually one selects only the
most energetic as that has the higher
chance of containing something
interesting but all the others are also
interesting so there is the democracy of
collisions you know something
interesting can come up so I don't know
if Ben is gonna talk about this but
that's something that is it's quite fun
to do how to make the most of this
pileup that people think is just noise
it's junk we have to discard it no
there's still interesting information
there so this is the picture that we saw
in the talk yesterday the amount of LHC
data in CDs now it's probably going to
be your stock and price I donno or rocks
but so these are some numbers that one
can come up with forty million
collisions per second up to multiply
that times the amount of data per
collision so I'm thinking about one of
the big experiments basic data packet
it's one megabytes and then you get to
40 terabytes per second you multiply
that by the approximate running time of
the LHC it doesn't work all the time but
it does work day and night when
does and then you get to two quantities
that are bigger than Facebook in 2014
but of course there's always a bigger
fish as the Craig stock said yesterday
of course there's the other commercial
company makes more data than the LHC but
they also have more money than us so
that's that's one thing that we need to
think about how to frequently process
all the data from all these channels of
the detector and this includes also
calibrating and aligning that is
detector so that the data that comes out
is is already ready for analysis and
then we need to select only the
interesting events the problem in
principle though is that we don't know
what interesting is in advance as we've
seen before there are particles that
have been discovered before they were
theorized so if we have just based our
selection on what we think exists we
woulda missed us so there's some
parallels with astrophysics and one is
that there's this firehose team this is
a slide that I pulled from an LHC be
talk where there's a the trigger system
of the experiment it's like drinking
from a firehose and then yesterday
there's the two days ago there was the
LSD talk at this workshop that says are
we building a fire hose LSD is the data
producer so that makes me conclude that
the LHC is also one of the data fire
forces that we have so it's a it's nice
thing how to transform it into a nice
community fountain so another parallel
with astrophysics is that to try and
make the to set the scene of what the
trigger does so we've seen that the LSST
data broker spots the interesting events
and then what you want you want to
trigger a follow-up without an
instrument and the limited resource in
this case is the follow-up instrument
time and that also cost money and the
cost of not following up what happens to
you if you don't point the instrument to
that the place where LS the data broker
has told you to is that you're missing
some interesting transient for the NHC
is something similar you spot an
interesting event with a very coarse
data reconstruction and then that can
trigger the recording of the event for
further analysis the limited resource in
this case is the data taking bandwidth
this is one of many also computing as a
a question but let's just think about
that for the moment and the cost of not
recording that event is that that event
is the DLC has produced it for you but
you've discarded it so it will cost LHC
money somehow because we've built this
machine to recreate that category of
events because you need to build another
and let's see if you forget to record a
given category so it's a fairly heavy
cost for for particle physics to not
optimize the trigger system question on
that please correct me if I'm wrong but
for LHC to spot an interesting event
they already have to have the definition
of interesting characterized right in
there is it flexible enough I think that
that's what I'm covering in so there's
their systems LHC is going towards a
trigger less readout because for them
the definition of interesting is
different respected Atlas and CMS but
yet that's the the fear and terror of
all experimentalist are not triggering
on the events I want so how do you
define interesting and this plot is a
bit busy but it's this is the the
transfers energy or the past particle
mass of the process that you care about
and this is in units of Barnes because
Barnes of course is a big thing and the
cross-section is a big thing apparently
but it's it's really tiny it's 10 to the
minus 27 or so centimeters this is the
cross-section of a process and the
number of expected events is a product
of the luminosity that you can collect
times the the cross-section so this is
the cross-section and the luminosity are
directly proportional to how many events
you see in your detector so here in
terms of cross-sections this is the LHC
somehow the LHC cross-section it's order
Barnes and then what is interesting to
Atlas and CMS is six orders of magnitude
lower you have the W and the Z at the up
there at their mass and then you have
the Higgs boson that is still three
orders of magnitude lower so there's a
big difference between what you could
take and what you actually want to take
for letv the situation is likely
different because the cross sections of
the processes that they're interested in
are much higher so they have a different
kind of problems they have they want to
take all possible events because you
could look for something that is rare in
this sea of sea but the other problem
that both Atlas and CMS and LHCb have is
that what if we're aiming to discover a
new rare process that is just buried in
one of these high rate backgrounds and
we can't distinguish at the trigger
level you just have to take it and do
the analysis later with this principle
you just discard it because you're not
taking all the events so let's have
another look at the standard model in
that in that sense and there's two
things that I wanted to take out from
this plot but this here you see this the
cross section and there's many orders of
magnitude between the inclusive of all
the events that one can take when a
proton proton collision and what starts
being interesting so the W production
here and these are called frequent
processes now now we have plenty of w
plenty of Z that's a very different
situation in which the first W was
celebrated at UA 1 now we don't know
what to do with them but there's also
there's processes that are more rare but
still quite frequent and you have this
production of TT bar events single top
then you start producing to bosons at
the same time and you go down a few
orders of magnitude as well so in this
case is you have one interesting events
every 10 to the 6th roughly this is your
ballpark estimate and the other thing
that is interesting to see in this plot
is that you have the theory on the back
of the data so the data is the colored
and the theory is the is the gray box
and you see that pretty much everything
is well line up so is that a good thing
or a bad thing
many people would just cherish a theory
that tells you so such precise things
about the nature of your fundamental
particles we hate the standard model and
I don't understand it but yeah the point
is that we one thing that I want to
point out is that this turnabout is
really remarkable in in doing what its
to do and we are probing it with very
high precision but there's another side
to it why are we doing that and that is
we're trying to solve some problem that
it has and there's a number I'm just
bringing up two and one is a dismal
Yama's definition of aesthetic art
problem
the standard model is not pretty as is
because the higgs mass needs very needs
a large correction that you don't know
where it comes from
so it's said to find the Higgs boson
mass is fine-tuned and a theory that
it's fine-tuned is not beautiful there's
also other problems that are like more
because there's something that we see
and the an empirical problem is that we
have something that is dark matter in
the universe
so unless gravity is wrong but you know
maybe it's right after the gravitational
wave measurements maybe there's a new
particle and that new particle is not in
the standard models so this is a large
problem the standard model not being
able to this to describe 75% of your
universe so one can think about the
standard model as a low-energy
approximation of more complete theory
and there's a lot of different theories
that can explain the shortcomings but
none of them is yet favored by data we
don't have any evidence of physics we
understand our model in LHC data and
they can all give very different
detector signatures some of them are
buried in the high rate background some
of them are rare but unusual so making
the most of LHC data really means to be
able to enable discoveries by ensuring
that all categories of these events are
selected or recorded now I'll show you
the LHC experiment trigger system and
since I'm going a little slower than
expected I will let you watch the video
by yourself which is possible well maybe
not the presentation wants me to see
this okay but this is maybe interesting
because it shows you how the trigger
works there's a first pass that is an
electronic press election that passes a
number of events a fairly large number
of events and then puts them onto a
software system generally that select
more and assemble all the information
from all this
the sub detector so there's a these two
levels there's a first electronic just
hardware level to make a course decision
but fast decision and then there's a
second level that's a high level high
level trigger and then after the high
level trigger has made a decision then
everything gets sent to computing
centers and then the tape storage and
then to the the LHC were what great yeah
that's what I'm that's what I'm saying
here so how do you trigger and here I
make the separation between the online
words so this is closer to the detector
and the offline world when you recorded
the experiment the the event then you
can analyze it later so the the first
step is a fast hardware section that is
100 kilohertz for the fur Atlas and CMS
and data again rate and then there's a
computer firm that does the second
process the second step of the selection
and reduces it to about 1 kilohertz
which is the limit that we can this is a
hard limit with the current technology
we can't record more than that and it's
partly it's because we can't store it we
could possibly record more but we don't
know where to put it
so these are the current trigger systems
in Atlas CMS and LHCb
and here it's just some numbers you have
a 40 megahertz bunch crossing and then
in less than 2.5 microseconds you have
to reduce this the data taking rate to
100 kilo hertz and then you have a
longer time once you have fewer events
for for software for doing a software
decision at the high level trigger and
these are farms of approximately 20,000
course probably more now I've not
updated the most recent numbers and then
you go to storage at 1 kilohertz in case
of atlases EMS and slightly higher for
for letv excuse me the kilohertz
that's events per second yeah
so this is a more detail of the Atlas
trigger I'm not going to go into details
of every every step but one interesting
point here is that there's a every
single detector will give information
out so a very important part of the
trigger is combining all this different
part of information so how do you
parallelizing and the multiplexing are
big part in in all this different in all
the different systems and the big
challenge for data acquisition is also
reading out all these channels that is
that comes from the detector and that's
why some upgrades are done on the
readout side to improve the trigger I'm
not sure you mean in what are you what
are you storing everything if we can do
a lot so you can go from really broad
detector information and you save it for
example the cells we can do a high level
it's it's appear the architecture for
for what we store and I'm sure Tony
knows more than I do but still it's a
you start you can have everything and
then you can have just the final state
particles in there so it can be anywhere
in between okay do you ever so you're
throwing out of there to go to the
bathroom
basically one out of every four thousand
disaster savings to the restaurants
right now okay so are you are you ever
storing data in a lossy format so you do
compression of the date of it it's
already done
yeah it's not done yet is that a loss
lossless or a lossy compression
maybe Paulo wants to I mean the
technical details for the data but I
don't know what you mean with lossy or
lossless so you throw out a bunch of
information but there are other events
that you might want to have save but you
don't have enough for it is there any
value in storing a lossy version of yes
so that's what that's the main point of
the talk I think in this case the
trigger mechanism is there's a highly
biased sampling mechanism yeah so yeah
so you could smooth that a little smooth
that somehow and well well if the
trigger is this is conceived as a film
as a as a filter with sharp cut offs
then and you're afraid of losing stuff
because you're throwing it away
well then sample what you sample what
you would have thrown away take a little
bit of the BAM that's done actually so
this is called pre scaling on triggers
so you you take even completely minimum
but random triggers minimum completely
minimum bias your bias just take
everything but it take a very very
little bit so that is always there in
the in the background but it's a very
small fraction of the right anything
well that's been nobody can do with it
yes
right so for quick details about the
different triggers this is just a random
selection of things that I find
interesting that there's many other
things that are interesting so the first
thing that I found interesting is that
the at last fast tracker so tracking is
an expensive thing in general so it it
costs CPU it to reconstruct tracks out
of space points and as if you do as much
as possible on on closer to the detector
then you can propagate this kind of
information that it would not have at
level one because it's too expensive to
get so the atlas fast tracker is a it's
a way to do pattern recognition within
the within associative memory chips that
match the data to partners that exist to
make this process of the track
recognition pattern recognition faster
so this is what in very very brief and
and you want to do this because if you
have a track then you can see if your
collision event is coming from the
vertex that has the most energy so it's
possibly interesting or one of the other
vertices so this is one of the reasons
why you want tracking as as fast as
possible so you can discard pile up
there's another detail that is a reality
sure it does not operate a hundred
percent of the time there's a time scene
between the runs the the physics runs or
there's machine development or there's
even within between the different
punches you could squeeze some time out
so why not storing the events and then
during that time letting the computer
farm do the processing so this is what
Alexei does in various ways you have a
duty cycle that is about thirty percent
of the time just this is an
approximation and then here you have a
farm that use where you store the data
you buffer it and then you do the
reconstruction for selecting more events
while the LHC is not running
another detail is that in in the upgrade
that is going to come in a few years
time so this is this not the big upgrade
that Atlas and CMS are doing it's an
intermediate upgrade for for us but for
LHCb is a bigger upgrade they're going
to try and go completely triggers so try
and have a software high level trigger
that will give you up to two to five
gigabytes per second rate of storage and
this is because they essentially at
every event it's going to be signal for
them so they don't want to discard they
want they don't want to bias their
selection and so you move the entire
analysis to the trigger and you increase
the capability of the HLT farm so this
is what Josh was saying you try and do
as much as possible that requires the
full detector information and the high
levels trigger and then discard that
information so that your event is
smaller so this is a takeaway point this
if you think every grant is interesting
you probably want to move towards the
trigger less readout it's very it's
pretty much impossible to do for artists
in CMS for various reasons but that's
what LHCb is doing and then another
detail is what CMS is and outlets are
also doing is to try and have a full
tracking information at the first level
of the trigger because you need to
reject if you were taking events like
you were taking now the rate of events
due to pileup would be already
unsustainable so you'd have to pre scale
and in throw away events at random that
are signal
no pileup or no is that our pilot so
Atlas and CMS plan to provide trucks to
two level one so you can already perform
this selection at that level and reject
events with pileup so this is an example
for CMS they want to provide trucks at
40 megahertz and they have two steps and
one is the detector on detector rate
data reduction where you decide what
stubs of trucks pass to pass to the
pattern recognition so you already
reduce the amount there are really large
amount of trucks based on the fact that
if you have you used the curvature of
the truck and the relation with its
momentum so that you have an expectation
that a track that starts here
if you
above a certain momentum is going to end
up in this region here and you discard
things that are more curved because they
are lower energy so this is already
reducing a lot of the rate and then
there's a number of possibilities
they're still designing them real time
pattern recognitions that are mostly
implemented in FPGAs right
Asics so this is a nice summary of all
of those and then finally before we
start with the physics part how do we
decide what record we have a limited
bandwidth we have many many interests
many interests for example Ben and I
love Jets so Jets are the products of
quarks and gluons and they they fragment
and they you see a spray of particles in
the detector this is also the thing that
happens the most of the LHC so if you
decide to just listen to the two of us
you take 100 percent of jets and then no
one would record w's anymore because
there's so many jets we can do that so
what the experiment does what is define
a trigger menu that is generally defined
at the beginning of a data taking period
and this is a menu that has to fit
within the bandwidth that that one has
so that one one kilohertz and you adapt
the cuts of each of the objects based on
their rates so you'll see that this is
the PT cap so the energy cut at the d
HLT let's look at a 2015 one and you see
that the threshold for the single
electron is much lower than the
threshold for the single jet trigger
that has to do with the fact that Jets
are much more frequent so in order to
have a and all this distribution fall so
I don't know if I have this
maybe I'm saying obvious things but this
is the PT of an object and this is the
number of events that you have and so if
you just measure the PT of the object as
a function the the number of events this
function of PT of the object these
things are falling so if you make a cup
up to here you're recording this part so
the the rate of events after a certain
cut it's smaller than before certain
cuts so that's why the you make a cut
the higher level trigger and this cut is
much is this is this threshold here it's
a more or less flexible kind of menu so
you decide at the start but you can if
you see something very very interesting
then you might decide that you want to
devote more of your bandwidth to a given
channel that you found interesting so
there's a it depends on there's chunks
usually chunks of data data periods and
these are the ones where you make big
changes to the menu the trigger menu so
this could it depends on the LHC
schedule could be weeks it could be one
week could be a month I mean that order
but one single run is I think not more
than a few days you can also change in
between the single physic runs but it's
less likely that you're going to because
it's our release it's a yeah yeah you
also wanted to test what's happening
yeah questions about explore exploit in
previous talks and other fields is there
some sort of 1% save or just let's let's
randomly save yeah yeah there is there's
a menu
just yeah so there's random trigger
setup I've cut out if you want to know
everything about the Atlas triggers
there's over there
yeah it's not it's really not good
it's really squeezing everything you
want you can it's 1% of the 1% of the
stuff they say so one thing that I found
interesting and I I don't know if Atlas
or CMS to it atlas I'm not sure so you
must might but I don't have the
information is that you can use you can
optimize this dynamically so you just
throw your optimization criteria to an
MBA and then you let the MBA decide on
these cuts so this is what LHCb is
trying to do it's about weight division
but in any case you risk two things one
is that you don't record enough events
because maybe the process that you're
interested in has produces jets at 200
and what we're doing below 360s to its
pre scaling the trigger so you're only
taking one every ten or one every 100
one every million so you're really
shooting yourself in the foot if you
really want that kind of signal and the
other problem is that if you're here
it's a single electron single mean these
are single physics objects so it's
fairly generic but what if it's an
electron that looks doesn't quite look
like an electron that might have decayed
far away in the detector and then has
produced a shower of things that's not
an electron anymore so you don't trigger
on it so these kind of classes of events
you risk missing them and people are
thinking about this problem there was a
workshop I think about a year ago so
people are really worried about this
camping does every event correspond to a
single collision or can you have a kind
of cascade of collisions that
put together signal and event so in
every event has some contribution from
previous and collisions before a
collision after so this is the basic but
you can't have physics models so if you
have I don't you have the two protons
that collide right and then you get I
don't know could you have three protons
collide yeah right it's less likely
multi-party interactions happen but you
can yes and then you typically you
twenty back to the vertex line that sort
of thing you can scattering debris here
as well right yeah yeah that's also
something that is always but there's
also models that actually impose that is
happening so new physics models where
you have a particle that waits to decay
and then decays a few bunch crossings
after your collisions has happened so
you find it on top of another collision
and this isn't convenient so you look
for these kind of events in empty punch
crossings so if something that shoots up
then it might be a sign of those
particles or a cosmic ray right so why
should we do better and because we don't
know what to expect from from new
physics and here is that I take an
expression from from one of the talks on
the gravitational wave sometime in the
first day your heart is broken if you
lose data so what do we do to minimize
heart breaks you want to analyze as much
data as possible as fast as possible
so this is the paradigm shift that I was
talking about where you try and do as
much data reduction as much data
processing at the trigger level so that
you discard the information that is that
you don't need to redo that you can also
save the data for later reconstruction
I'm not talking about this but if you
have the storage resources and you don't
have the computing
sources just Park the data somewhere and
then whenever the LHC is in a long
technical stop your construct later and
one can also implement more refined and
unexpected trigger algorithm see so I've
pointed to two local experts if you want
to to ask here so let's move on to the
real-time use case number one why do we
want to do this so we see that the
bandwidth is event rate time bed size so
if you make the amount side smaller then
you can take more events that's very
very logical and this is an important
limitation when you have very high rate
backgrounds anybody can really select
because everything is interesting and
this is also important because low rate
processes are what would not actually
look for because we haven't had data do
it and at the moment the LHC luminosity
will increase more than the energy so
this is the kind of process we want to
look for so we move from the synchronous
data analysis where you record as much
as possible and then analyze later to a
real-time data analysis where you
reconstruct and analyze data right after
it's recorded and then in throw away all
the information needed for the
reconstruction you just save the high
level physics objects and yesterday
we've heard keep only the science
content somehow that that's a similar
thing you're trying to keep the high
level objects electrons photons things
like that there's problems in in both
because they're synchronous data
analysis the problem is that the output
is large and you're fixing it here and
the high luminosity you can't you always
have to raise the threshold so you're
going to miss some physics but if you
want to do a very refined data analysis
then you need all this information so
you can't just go and say I'm going to
throw everything away because you might
regret it and in real-time data analysis
is great that it's the output is small
so you collect more data with less
storage but it does require more online
computing power so you have to
reconstruct these events you have to
pass them through the high level trigger
and you can't go back and reconstruct so
these are the two paths though if you
have a decision you always have to make
a decision at the trigger level so you
have some unrefined data analysis so it
doesn't cost very much to use the same
information that you've used to make the
decision
and just save that information in a
special stream and this is the analysis
with trigger objects and only if the
trigger has passed then you go to the
standard stream where you record
everything so we have two different
streams in in Atlas CMS and LHCb and
it's very important that you do at this
point that the reconstruction that you
perform offline after you recorded the
whole event is the same as the one that
you do online so that you can't have the
same quality of the object so this is
very good for in general because you
improve the trigger you improve the
trigger decision as well when you make
this algorithms the same it's not
obvious that they are and then LHCb has
managed to do a full on real-time
calibration where the visitor where the
resolution is really the same this is
for tracks
between online and offline and this is
possible thanks to the computing power
of the h LT forms so what's the use case
here you know how the question is trying
to look the effect of luminosity in a
situation if you have a very low
luminosity but you are very lucky and
you can get single color single single
events in this particular detective
detector Arthur imagined are there
possible events that swamp the current
design single events the swamp current
design of the detector to detect so that
even even if you capture as this as this
detector can describe those events you
you haven't haven't acquired the
information to begin with
with a detector or or do you make the
assumption that well the of all the
possible events even the fuzzy ones
around the edge our detector could see
one of those if it happened I think we
make the assumption that we could see it
so we do have runs where we impose that
there's only one College so we we put
the beams in a such configuration that
where you only have one interaction at
the same time I don't know if that
answers your question the doctor can see
that yeah you can see either if the
detector then in principle prefers not
to have pileup it would be nicer if
quasi theory doesn't imagine any kind of
interaction that would be invisible that
would be too complex for the detector to
do this so you would saturate the
detector readout you mean ambiguous
because you weren't getting you're
getting right combination of spatial
resolution and energy I don't know I
think it's possible if you have
particles if you have a process that
leaves your particles start too soft for
example they all Bend and they don't
actually get to your to your detector so
this is the kind of it there's theories
where anything can happen essentially
but then you can use different
techniques so you try and you try and
see if there's something in the initial
state so proton one of the partners of
the proton has radiated a glue one for
example and you use the glue on to
target event and then you see missing
energy physical assumptions built into
this particular detector mechanism and
from which you start to degrade yes so
there are I think there are there are
events that we are possibly missing
because we are not doing the
reconstruction right for those
particular events so things that the
trucks that start too late
you might discard them because you think
there are no is but they're not actually
noise so people are thinking about that
as well so that's a structural problem
structural yeah yeah but there we're
trying to patch all of this right so I'm
not going to tell you what dark matter
is but I'm going to tell you a bit about
dark matter mediators because this is
what we're trying to do with indirect
detection direct detection and particle
colliders were assuming that the dark
matter is interacting with the stellar
model and we're trying to look for the
products of this
interaction so if you have a force you
can you will have a mediator this is
just looking at the contact interaction
versus when you found the W in the firm
interaction and so one can look for this
mediator in both invisible way and this
is one of the kind of events that maybe
you are mentioning that you we don't see
anything because the particles just
don't interact in our detector but you
look for it with the initial state
radiation from the from the quark and
then you look for the missing energy but
if the mediator has been produced from
standard model particles it will also
became standard other particles and for
this kind of particular models they're
very very simple so let's not take them
too seriously but if you try and connect
them to the Radek density then they have
to this in this shaded region and this
is the mediator mass and the y-axis and
Dark Matter on the x-axis and what we
want to see is the mediator you see that
there's a in very very quickly
the mediator masses above 100 GB 200 GB
start producing too much each other
this is not quite a dark matter model
anymore because you it doesn't explain
the relative density so there's an
interest Erica interest to look for
low-mass mediator and how would that new
particle new Mac Dark Matter mediator
manifest it will manifest like the Higgs
boson a bump in this case of two Jets
above a distribution of QCD that makes
also two Jets but is continuous it
doesn't have any features and this
mediator particle will appear with a
bump that is has a mass corresponding to
the mass of the mediator particle the
problem though is that in this case you
can't quite distinguish what is coming
from the mediator what is coming from
QCD so the only hope you have is to have
a very good resolution for your bump and
if you pre scaled the events so you're
throwing away at random then you were
really killing the statistical precision
of this because you're only taking these
events and with a very large weight so
if the signal has a small if the signal
is small then you can't see it so this
is what we're trying to fix here there
was an entire region of a phase space
where Dark Matter mediators were not
well not dark matter mediate
but in general these resins were not
looked up and the last experiments that
could do it were CDF anyway - and we
were just looking above so now with the
in analysis we call this a trigger level
analysis because it's a three-letter
acronym so it's a TL a CMS calls the
data scouting and the Lexi because turbo
stream but you can actually record only
the information necessary for this
search that is Jets and use the
information that is already available so
you take the Jets on the trigger level
and you see that for a very small
portion of the bandwidth so this blue
line here you can record you can take up
a lot of the rate so the rate of just
Jets is almost as big as all the other
events that you take simply because
you're taking a very small event size
and this is the increase in statistics
that you see so this is if you are doing
a pre scale trigger search and here you
get everything on pre scaled and CMS has
been doing it is since ATV and this now
a standard and now we are actually able
to fill the region that was interesting
here and then we're trying to think
about what to do here but we'll get
there this is the same plot as before
where there was a huge hole here now the
LHC has filled at home and in LHC be
they look for something that is sorry
I'm gonna be fast but I guess we had a
lot of discussion in the case for
real-time analysis also has to do with
Dark Matter connected particles it's
dark bosons they're not exactly the same
thing but they have something to do with
the mediators that we were looking at
before but you can also do measurements
okay you want to do charm physics as
precise as possible so you have to take
if you if you want to do a very precise
measurements you want to take as much
statistic as you can and then beat the
theory and 30 and this is one of the
most beautiful results that I've seen
this year I think this is the they've
taken an unbiased sample of the immune
events with this technique and you can
see all the QCD resonance really really
precisely and then in the places where
there's no QCD resonance they've tried
to set limits because i've not seen any
deviation on this dark both of particles
and the limit is here and it's a it's a
very low rate that we're constraining
here so yeah to finish we
look sorry I just think the bar actually
did better and so well we can talk about
that later but it's also that is a
really nice search I think ok so in the
last five minutes the monitoring and in
this case we use the same definition as
before
you want to do a data analysis as
promptly as possible so that you can fix
issues that could be either in your
trigger menu or in your detector itself
so there are people that are on shift
looking at a detector and checking
monitoring that the detector is taking
data correctly that the data quality is
good and you can take a decision that if
you fix the detector change the trigger
menu and the time scales involved here
from in close as quickly as possible
when you're on detector but for the data
taking you have more chances to really
construct for example so we can go up to
days and this is how you can ask how
much of the data that we take at the LHC
we can can we use and it's a fairly
large fraction here so this is the what
the LHC delivers and this is the
integrated luminosity on the y-axis and
the blue is the yellow is what Atlas
records because sometimes you have an
efficiency your detectors not ready or
something glitched or and the blue is
where all detector was considered
functioning and good enough so there's
not very much difference between these
two these two curves and this is how the
monitoring is done I'm sorry I can't go
into too much detail but it's a fairly
complex system that involves both online
and offline computing so you have
different data streams where you you
have a smaller data stream that you look
up right away for the checking the data
quality and then there's another loop
that can be done in order to for example
mask cells that are that are noisy this
is one of the things and this is yet not
completely automatized and I think there
is a lot to a lot of one can do with
anomaly detection of machine learning
and it's people are starting LHCb is
also starting do you really need a
person that looks at these histograms
and then tells you this is not looking
right or this is looking right yeah to
an extent but there's a lot that can be
done automatically so in LHC we do have
what
called robot shifters and this is
something that I've been developing I
think with Yandex so there is some
extent of machine learning that tells
you what is the likelihood that this run
is good or not using all the information
they have and training it on good runs
and the last thing is another maybe more
controversial way to do analysis
especially if you like blind analysis so
there could be a system that just looks
at all the distributions compares it to
the best estimate you have from
simulation of the background and tells
you if you have a bump or a signal or
something so this is what they call the
tada
I don't remember the acronym but it's a
just performing a predefined data
analysis I'm telling you if your Monte
Carlo is agreeing with the data and with
this they've spotted a lot of issues in
the calibrations for example not
necessarily I mean your physics but I
still think it's a it's useful it's a
web display based analysis right finally
I will conclude by saying that we're
just starting and we've taken we're
exploring the energy frontier because
the LHC is at the moment the machine
that has the highest energy center mass
energy for making new particles in a lab
so we should keep using it and this is
Fabiola Gianotti that says we have to
exploit it because we've built it so far
so we have to actually run it and make
the most of this data and we are here so
we're and this is our log scale here so
we're going we're going for a hundred
inverse time to burn so far I think in
total and we have to go to three three
thousand inverse time to burn so there's
a long way to go and how do we make the
most of this information
this is conclusions that we've drawn at
this in 2015 but they're still valid to
me so that we can move a lot of simple
analysis and searches to this lossy
format where you throw away most of the
information because you think that you
understand your objects well enough and
you use these techniques to do a lot of
the the measurements now you do it with
the full data set and leave space for
other things that might be more rare
phenomena that needs the full
reconstruction this one and then one
always needs to monitor calibrations and
conditions in real time
and do it as well as possible so that
you don't miss anything because your
detector had holes or because your data
again was an optimum and then finally
I'm particularly addressing those that
think that the LHC is a dead end there's
some unknown experimental is the thing
that yeah sure we have looked for
low-hanging fruit but it can actually
hit us in the eye and so we do expect
surprises from the data set we have
problems to solve and we especially at
the electroweak scale that there's a
very special scale that's where the
Higgs boson was found where the W and Z
boson in order to probe that scale with
first with with Jets and then also with
with leptons we will need this kind of
data taking techniques because the rates
of the data in that region are too high
and the last point is that there's we've
seen in this workshop that there's a the
real-time decision-making challenges are
cross field so there are ways to
collaborate on tools and infrastructure
and I put here a few links to the hip
Software Foundation roadmap white paper
that it could be a first starting point
to say okay we think what we need this
is what we thought we needed in LHC for
the next 20 years
what waters fields need are there
parallels and so on so there's there's
forums to discuss this so sorry for
using all my time I hope you can still
have the coffee break and thank you very
much we have time for maybe a couple of
questions before cut me yeah it's a
general question this is way outside my
area of expertise but I've always
wondered like for the Higgs boson
discovery what significance or signal
level was considered the threshold for
actually pronouncing that spike roughly
it's so white like why that throw good
question I think that's a very good
question that a good debate for ours and
if you put a statistician they're not
based in their you know entertainment
for days just it's really it's set
really high so I assume it's set so it
makes me a little suspicious
sort of false positive rate if you think
about it if what if your it tells you
what how many thought experiments so I'm
being frequent this year how many
thought experiments you'd have to have
and see the same amount of Hicks Bowden
like events if you just have background
so you can set that threshold as high as
you want it doesn't tell you that that
is exactly the explosion but it's it's
pretty high setting it so high is it
possible it's a misguided attempt to
account for the fact that you know there
may be other alternative explanations
for that or whatever but there's no way
to quantify that I mean there's no way
to just quantify the Aqua re probability
that takes on something else I think you
you you don't use the bump to tell it's
a Higgs boson so if you read the wording
of the initial discovery was we found a
new pose no mention of the Higgs because
in order yeah in order to see whether I
don't think I have the plot here but in
order to define that as a Higgs boson
you need to measure its properties so
this is a completely different suite of
measurements that you need to measure
the spin new admission charge you need
to check that all the couplings line up
on what you expect that your signal
strength is the same in all the channels
as you expect so that gives you more
confidence that it is actually exposed
the bump by itself doesn't tell you
anything there's a corollary in
astrophysics which was the quote unquote
discovery of dark energy be a supernova
was not announced as such it was the
discovery of the accelerating universe
even though our thought was that it had
to be dark energy Elemis that was not
set what was said was we made a
measurement in the university's
accelerator we also used five sigma that
is a standard thing I think it's been
around since the 40s or 50s in my energy
physics and I've little iron I believe
it's like her or not more than anything
else is that some people there were
experiments in the past that release
things early that turned out to be wrong
and and so they established this vise
it's not five Sigma statistical to be
clear right yeah this is including
system influences their mother Excel
yeah yeah yeah
say yes statistician there's no meaning
for statistician between statistical and
yeah this is a so a systematic it
includes biases and and the known biases
and maybe some accounting of the end
them that's where it gets very fuzzy
anyway exactly and how do you do this
statistics correlation but there's
people that have advocated doing burying
so having this a base impersonal
actually saying how difficult is your
analysis then you're if you're more if
it's more difficult you get penalized by
the number of segments that you need to
have so there are P there are papers on
the archive that say we should do that
you know
so you ever sized it that the fast
trigger has to be close to the metal
because you you're going to be doing
things right off the detector and you
don't want to be you don't you're gonna
be a less bandwidth-limited close to the
metal so I think a million questions
about that but I will try to boil it
down to one which is that as you're
gonna want to be look how much work is
done on these Hardware triggers in real
time like like presumably every time you
do some kind of upgrade each of these
experiments goes in and makes hardware
changes in their Hardware triggers like
how what is it like being adaptive I
mean obviously these experiments are
very adaptive and they're going to
attach further on and as physics hints
appear you can adapt how much of the
adaptation
at the hardware level and how does that
work are you guys replacing the hardware
triggers every upgrade I think it's you
have to replace both the readout because
sometimes your detector itself is not
fast enough to give the information to
the to your trigger system the trigger
system is not something it's not
unintelligent necessarily intelligent
thing it just receives information makes
a decision so how fast you get the
information is important so for that
reason sometimes you have to replace the
tracking if you want to help track
trigger and so is their constant
hardware work at the metal well at that
level inside the system as you go up in
energy you're also getting hardware yeah
yeah you tend to keep it constant when
it's when it contacts is it because the
election is running so that you can't
fix but all the rest of the time people
are replacing yeah we're not used to but
that is real-time in some sense because
you will adapt those things to like it's
an interesting it's real-time because
you mean there's feedback because it's
not yeah there's someone told you in the
previous run the pileup is going up to
400 you need a completely different
effective because it died yeah would be
cool to go into LSST and just totally
change the filters is more like changing
the silicon like the gems which we don't
do we do that like once every 10 years
right yeah so there's the harbingers of
power trains that sometimes I'm just off
detector so I think because that's like
off detector it's like meters away so we
can physically go and take it what's up
I was being facetious if any neighbor
just came out saying that it could be
that all astronomical sea
I mean the other kind of hardware
trigger question I had this is related
to the light comb thing which is that
they give this collision and then the
information when that collision is
expanding as a spear the bigger detector
the more of that sphere you have to
integrate and get into your hardware
detector so it's a very easy question of
whether the hardware detectors could
somehow be more local on light because
right now the hardware detectors have to
integrate this whole sphere to make this
but not necessary
I mean I'm talking about an example that
I guess is easy for me to understand
that it's wrong one I'm not really an
expert of the track triggers but there's
there's ways to do it like that but you
can just look at the region of interest
so you have something that informs you
where most of the action is and then
just read that out so it freezes right
now the inner detector like the the
inner most layers of our detector they
are not used for the hardware level
trigger oh we only use the parts that
are far away from the detector to do the
triggering because if you just can't
read it up and press it's passing and
then I'm right I was gonna ask about
that to a million then you also have a
light slower light cone inside your
electron weight so that the light comes
it takes like 20 nanoseconds for a
particle to go through the whole thing
it takes 200 nanoseconds there's
actually the light coming the first
light cone is actually specced yeah
compared to like the bunch passing all
right let's uh thank Katarina again and
we can ask more questions
[Applause]